so how did you first come across this
omo moa
well i heard about it when it was
discovered on october 19th
2017 and after a week or so
it was uh it became quite intriguing
in the sense that you know we realized
it's the first interstellar object
looks a little bit strange in terms of
its shape
and so i had a discussion with
yuri milner a russian israeli
science funder in silicon valley
about using radio telescopes to which
he had access through
a project called breakthrough listen and
trying to see if there is any radio
signal
coming from this object we checked it
and
put an upper limit of roughly the
transmission of a cell phone
so clearly omomua was not transmitting
at the frequencies that we were looking
at the radio frequencies
it could have been transmitting at other
frequencies could have been transmitting
in a different direction
but we ruled out the possibility that
anything in our direction was more than
the power of a cell phone and
um so at that point you know i thought
well it must must be probably natural
but then six months later there was the
report about
uh it showing exhibiting an extra push
away from the sun
and that could not be explained in terms
of a cometary tale because we haven't
seen any
and at that point you know that was the
straw that they broke the camel's back
in
in in my vocabulary uh in terms of
me saying to myself look it's so unusual
maybe we should look for something out
of the box to explain it
and i wrote a couple of articles in
scientific american talking about it
being
a technological artifact or relic
and then wrote a scientific paper about
it in october 2018
uh that um got a lot of attention we
didn't have any press release it just
became viral in the media and
uh after that i wrote the number of
papers on the mobile and its
implications
so you mentioned it was moving
away from the sun well when we
discovered it it was already receding
away from us yes
it's sort of like having a guest for
dinner
and realizing that the guest is
interesting uh when the guest
goes out the front door into the dark
street and
uh that was unfortunate because we
couldn't chase it
at that point if we were to discover it
in july
instead of october and by the way i was
visiting
that observatory the pan stars
observatory on mount
haleakala in maui just around
that time july 2017 with my family
we were on vacation in in maui and i
gave a seminar there
and at the time nobody knew about umuah
if we were to know about it then we
could have contemplating
uh sending out a spacecraft equipped
with a camera
along its path and then getting a better
view of what it looks like
unfortunately we didn't know and so it
was too late for us to chase it
afterwards
and the the moral of this story is that
if we find another weird object in the
future
on its approach to us we better send the
camera
that will take a photograph of it and
you know a picture is worth a thousand
words
right now is that something that you
think we'll be able to do next time one
of these
is coming close to us yeah i think it's
quite possible and
science is all about the evidence and
it's about reproducibility the ability
to
study something again and again when it
repeats
and then in this case given the fact
that panstas looked
uh surveyed the sky for a few years
before he discovered this object
we should definitely find another one
that looks like it within a few years
from now
because it's otherwise it's very
unlikely that we found
a rare object just within a few years
now what were the main differences
between this and other things that you
see like asteroids or comets or
something like that obviously the shape
was different
and yeah the shape the shape was more
extreme it was
projected on the sky uh ten times longer
than
it is wide and imagine uh
a a piece of paper tumbling in the wind
even if it's razor thin the chance of it
being exactly edge-on
is very small so most of the time you
know it would change the amount of
area that you see but the change by a
factor of 10 or more is
is quite extreme and the second is that
you know we infer that it's most likely
flat based on the
amount of light that it reflected as it
was stumbling
what do you think it was what do you
think it legitimately was
well i think it was probably a very thin
object
artificially produced and probably
dysfunctional not something that is
being used for spying on us or
some other purpose
simply because it was tumbling it was
out of control in a way
but also if you think about it we sent
out voyager 1 voyager 2
new horizons all kinds of space junk
and a million years from now all of this
will be real junk in the sense that it
will not be functional anymore
so if you wait long for long times you
know the
these objects that are being sent into
space may not
continue to be functional they don't
have enough energy
supply to keep them functional and
there might be a lot of them floating in
space just like plastic bottles in the
ocean you know that are swept ashore and
we kind of
find them many every now and then so
it's sort of like waste
uh filling up interstellar space and
every now and then we will bump into one
now could you define exactly what
interstellar does that mean
not bound to the sun yeah interstellar
well in general more generally
interstellar means between stars
and um in this so in this context you
can say oh momo
came from the space between stars
it came into the solar system from
outside the solar system
the question about its origin is not
answered because we don't know where it
came from
it was actually another weird fact about
it is that it was
situated in a special frame of reference
it was
uh in the local standard of rest which
is the frame that you get to
when you average over the motions of all
the stars in the vicinity of the sun
and the um was at rest in that frame
so it's sort of like finding a car that
is parked
at rest in a public parking lot
you cannot really tell which house it
came from because all the stars in the
case of the local standard of rest
all the local stars are moving relative
to that frame
only one in 500 stars is so much at rest
relative to the local standard of rest
as umu was
one way to think about it it was like a
beauty sitting on the surface of the
ocean
and the solar system bumped into it
because the sun is moving relative to
that frame
and you may ask what purpose does it
serve being in that special frame
you know one possibility is that there
is a grid of such objects
and they serve as road posts when you
navigate through interstellar space
you can find your coordinates where you
are relative to those objects
another possibility is that it's a relay
station for communication that
um you don't need to communicate across
large distances you just communicate by
the signal
hopping from one relay station to the
next we use this
approach on earth now what did you say
the name of
the name of the telescope that was being
the new telescope the billion dollar
the vera rubin oh the name of the
telescope that we surveyed the sky
you mean yeah you mentioned that there
was like a billion dollar telescope
being built in chile
well there is the vera rubin observatory
that will um
be much more sensitive than uh
the pan stars telescope that was that
discovered
in hawaii and it will be in chile yes
okay and then the primary focus of that
will be to
discover these things before it's too
late yeah discover near-earth objects
uh with much greater sensitivity than
pan stars and
it will be able to find about two-thirds
of
those that the congress tasked nasa to
find
you know so 60 percent of the entire
population